she's a British novelist best known as
the author of the Harry Potter fantasy
series the books have gained worldwide
attention won multiple awards and have
sold over 400 million copies in 2004
Forbes named her the first person to
become a billionaire by writing books
she's JK Rowling and here are her top 10
rules for success failure gave me an
inner security that I had never attained
by passing examinations failure taught
me things about myself that I could have
learned no other way I discovered that I
had a strong will and more discipline
than I had suspected I also found out
that I had friends whose value was truly
above the price of rubies the knowledge
that you have emerged wiser and stronger
from setbacks means that you are ever
after secure in your ability to survive
you will never truly know yourself or
the strength of your relationships until
both have been tested by adversity such
knowledge is a true gift for all that it
is painfully won and it has been worth
more than any qualification I ever
earned I was on the train from
Manchester to London and it came just
came had something like that ever happen
to you before yes truthfully I mean
other ideas had just come to me because
I think if you're a writer and that's
what you spend a huge amount of time
doing you do ideas do come to you but
nothing had ever come so with such a
high hattis I thought god I'd love to
write that and when I got off the train
I went straight home and I started
writing it is one of the amazing and
wonderful things about literature as
about film and music is it's utterly
subjective so somebody's acting the
point of it you know that's the point of
course you won't you move in that world
if you expect us just stand under a
shower of Perpetual praise there's
something wrong with exactly that you
know you will you will get criticism I
knew that going in and the funny thing
is I'm not particularly I was never a
very confident person in their areas in
my life in which I'm very thin-skinned
but not in this area
in this area I I think it's right and
proper I should be criticized and that's
that's engage Euler did you write in
here mm-hmm
this is really the room where I finished
philosophers cloning here this is really
where I turned my life around completely
and we made my life changed so much in
his flat I feel I really became myself
here in that everything stripped away I
made such a mess of things but that was
all that was freeing so I just thought
well I want to write so I write the book
and what what is the worst that can
happen he gets turned down by every
publishing written thing to you so you
know it's really back to the whole time
here my bedrooms are locked well my
bedroom the bedroom it's a lot tidier
than Oh God God that's mad this was a
tip when I have to all that Harry Potter
books now that is really freaky and for
years now I felt that if it all
disappeared and some days I do feel like
it
is it real then this is where I would
come back to you know this would be my
body based line I'd be back in Leith and
obviously if I'd known that tenure well
what was it two year ten years old I'd
come back here with a film crew and
there would be my published books in
someone else's bookcase in this room I
mean it's really incredible to me
you really did I mean yes
because it's such a well-worn part of my
story now it's a big yarn to hear how I
wrote it as though it was all some sort
of publicity stunt I did for a year but
it was my life and it was very hard and
I'd know that was could be this
fairytale recession I might I've coming
back it was just full of ghosts
I remember once and it was like it was
like well like I'm gonna call it clash a
flash of clairvoyance now obviously if I
hadn't come true I would just be around
and crazy for a dad but I do remember
one day writing philosopher's stone I
was walking away from the cafe where
I've been working Philosopher's Stone
which became weightless which became
sorceress knowing exactly so that's the
first novel mhm and I had this moment
where I suddenly thought it was like
another voice speaking to me in the
voice said the difficult things going to
be to get published if it's published it
will be huge Wow and that is exactly
what it was so there was some hint that
the voice had said to you well the thing
is you've got to believe haven't you yes
you know I was I was not the world's
most secure person um I wasn't someone
with an enormous amount in fact I'd say
I was someone with not much self belief
at all and yet in this one thing in my
life I believed that was the one thing
in my life I felt I can tell a story
there's always trepidation I mean I
think that people might be surprised to
know that I felt trepidation every time
I produced a Potter book you know the
weight of expectation there was was I
won't say crushing it was extraordinary
and wonderful to have that weight of
expectation but a duty with yourself
yeah and with the expectations latterly
of millions of fans all of whom were
very invested in the story and wanted to
see what they wanted to see and I knew
where I was going and I I had to put on
mental blinkers a lot and just think I
know where I'm going I must not be
influenced by this
given a time Turner I would tell my 21
year old self that personal happiness
lies in knowing that life is not a
checklist of acquisition or achievement
your qualifications your CV
are not your life though you will meet
many people of my age and older who
confuse the two life is difficult and
complicated and beyond anyone's total
control and the humility to know that
will enable you to survive its
vicissitudes I often get asked by
younger readers what I would advise if
you want to be a writer
this is the way I did it so that's the
only advice I can give
you've got to read as much as you
possibly can because that's the best way
to recognize good writing and to learn
what makes bad writing and those are
very good things you'll probably go
through a phase where you imitate your
favorite writers that's perfectly okay
that's another learning process you
resign yourself to writing lots and lots
of rubbish you just got to write that
out of your system and sooner or later
you'll hit what you know you really
should be doing and what is your genre
and perseverance you've got to persevere
because it is a it's a career with a lot
of knock backs but the rewards are huge
I don't mean in the sense that if that's
what you really want to do to be able to
do it life long is the best thing in the
world very rewarding but it's not a
career for people who are easily
discouraged that's for sure and to their
parents don't tell them it's unrealistic
never to never say that because even if
they're not published writing
well writing is the passion of my life
so it's an important thing to do always
always always wanted to be a writer and
obviously you want to be a writer you
want to you dream of supporting yourself
through writing definitely
but here is a bit of both because I was
very much aware that children's books
you do not the possibility of supporting
yourself solely by writing children's
books is slim that's that's the reality
of it which I was fully aware of that so
in in that sense this is all come as a
huge enormous shock I'm delighted
because I always wanted to write and
always have written but my realistic
side has not allowed me to dream of half
of what's happening to me
truthfully if you choose to use your
status and influence to raise your voice
on behalf of those who have no voice if
you choose to identify not only with the
powerful but with the powerless if you
retain the ability to imagine yourself
into the lives of those who do not have
your advantages then it will not only be
your proud families who celebrate your
existence that thousands and millions of
people whose reality you have helped
change we do not need magic to transform
our world we carry all the power we need
inside ourselves already we have the
power to imagine better thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because Natasha asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and we'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of JK
Rowling's top 10 tips' met the most to
you leave it in the comments we're going
to join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching have a great day
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon